and diagnostic pelvic laparoscopy is
used to examine the
internal organs of the pelvis to
identify a specific problem
you may be advised to have
a diagnostic pelvic laparoscopy if you
have pelvic pain, a mass,
abnormal fluid buildup, or difficulty
getting pregnant
and  this may be due to endometriosis
pregnancy tubal tumor or
ovarian cyst scarification due to
pelvic infections or other conditions
laparoscopic techniques require
only a minimal
keyhole or stab incision and
the recovery period is shorter
and less painful  when you arrive at the
hospital for the procedure
an intravenous line will be started and
you may be given a sedative
to help you relax the
pelvic laparoscopy is performed
under general anesthesia so you will be
asleep for the duration of the
operation a
breathing tube for l  into the mouth and
throat to help you breathe
during the operation
a catheter will be placed in your bladder to
drain urine
an uncomplicated diagnostic laparoscopy
may take 30 to
60 minutes
the surgeon will be able to access the interior of
the pelvis using  of
cutting instruments called
trocars, which will make a
small opening or port of entry
half an inch below the navel,
then carbon dioxide will be pumped
through the umbilical port of entry
to inflate the abdomen so that
its contents can be more easily visualized.
surgeon will insert the
laparoscope through the
umbilical port the camera images are
projected on a monitor in the operating room
the surgeon will carefully examine the
pelvic tissues and organs for
signs of disease that could
explain your symptoms may create other
ports through  of which instruments can be
slid these in
Additional instruments are used to displace
organs for better visualization or to
perform operative procedures such
as removing fibrous tissue, performing
biopsies, tissue sampling, or draining
abnormal fluid. When the laparoscope
and other instruments are removed,
a special gas valve is briefly left in place.
time to release
all the carbon dioxide from the abdomen
the keyhole incisions
are closed with a few
stitches or staples and then covered with
a bandage
after surgery the breathing tube will be removed
and
the area monitored  After a short
while, the catheter will be removed and pain
medication will be given
as needed. When you are able to
drink fluids, the IV will be removed.
Most patients
are discharged within hours
of the procedure.